seeing countries like Venezuela seeing
countries like the Soviet Union
how can you identify with socialism
when it's never worked
well that's interesting one let's start
with Venezuela so I think I think South
America is incredibly unique yeah
because because of the Monroe Doctrine
because of the fact that you have this
Global superpower to your North yeah the
United States never let social democracy
happen in South America it was not
allowed this happens in Guatemala with a
guy called our Benz in the 1950s he
really just wants to Institute a bit of
land reform and Trade union rights
really nothing radical nothing that
wasn't Happening by Social Democratic
parties in Europe the point was that
wasn't allowed that was not allowed so
this idea of well if only the South
Americans could have sort of mainstream
center-left politicians and they tried
it okay they were removed by military
coups and interestingly enough who was
in Guatemala in the 50s when that
happened Che Guevara yeah and he says
well they're not going to let us do that
then we've got to seize control by you
know by military means and actually
we're going to have to hold on to power
in a very different way so I think the
development of socialism in South
America it's supposed to make excuses
for anyone but I think the development
of socialism in South America is quite
unique and quite particular because
parliamentary Democratic Socialism or
social democracy like we have in Europe
was not allowed it was completely off
the table
um so that's parking that one and in
terms of socialism not working I suppose
and again I also wouldn't compare the
Soviet Union to Venezuela yeah I I think
Venezuela under Chavez did well because
of high oil prices so there was a sense
of of rising Prosperity uh and obviously
when oil prices went down that sort of
disappeared again I think with the
Soviet Union it was it was different in
so much as there was there was a
national project of of industrialization
too quickly but there was a different
kind of project it was reaching towards
a modernity in a different kind of way
to somewhere like Venezuela I feel I
might be wrong
um and and the Russian people and the
peoples of of the former Soviet Union I
think can be proud of certain
accomplishments such as the first person
in space the most incredible
technological achievement I think it's
an amazing achievement the defeat of
Nazism I think should be very proud of
that
um and there wasn't so much a
technological achievement but yeah yeah
well no but you know you're saying that
but um there's some really interesting
stuff about this about the ability of
the Soviet Union after 1940-41 to
actually start developing incredible
tanks incredible military technology
incredible but it could rival the
Germans there's a well in a way that
nobody predicts actually it's the other
way around interestingly so the Soviet
Union people don't know this because the
Soviets got overrun in in 41 and early
42. what actually happened is the
Soviets had far superior technology in
the early period but then they got
outpaced by the German uh military
machine as the war went on so by the end
of the war uh what the kind of
Technology the Germans had is the basis
of all our technology now they had
cruise missiles basically in their
thousand
Etc what and there's a reason the
Soviets lost 20 million people of course
World War II
um but you I mean look your point look
every society has positives in every way
of structuring it I guess the point that
uh Francis is making about it not
working is in the Soviet Union and in
Venezuela
the argument would be about socialism
that it is a way of thinking about the
world that is so unnatural to human
beings the way that we evolve to think
about our own interests and the
interests of others in the Soviet Union
as you know the idea was that you were
supposed to put the needs of the state
above the those of your own family that
it takes putting people in latumba or it
takes people in wouldn't being put into
gulags to achieve that dream in which
Pavlik marozov gives up his parents to
the state uh because it's such an
unnatural way that doesn't really apply
onto how human beings are white if we
were mole rats or ants where we were
genetically linked uh that might be
easier to do do you see what that that's
kind of more the argument no I think
that's and I think the 20th century has
a series of experiments like this from
Nazi Germany to the USSR to the Khmer
Rouge where you have this incredibly I
mean I don't even think
economic projects in extremely
cultural projects an extremely
Innovative as cultural project so like
the idea that a human being is a tabula
rasa black slay and look I I don't
I don't think that's necessarily doesn't
have to be Socialism or fascism or
anything like that I think it has a
certain interpretation of human nature
which was we now know is wrong we know
that doesn't function so why am I a
socialist I would actually I'm a Marxist
frankly and we'll get I can also go back
to a few what I would call success
stories regarding Democratic socialism
we'll pilot for a moment I'm a socialist
because I believe that workers generally
should be as uh close to the the product
of the labor as possible they should
have as little of it alienated from them
as possible which means a fair deal for
workers right so if a worker is creating
value per hour of 30 pounds an hour I
think they should be earning a
significant chunk of that clearly there
should be a little bit of profit there
should be some taxes and so on and so
forth but the idea that a worker should
be exploited from the products of the
labor I think is is a moral affront and
I think that to me I'm a Catholic but
that to me it's almost like that's
almost like an article of faith I think
a good society allows workers to enjoy a
significant share of the value that they
create
um in terms of Marxism I'm a Marxist the
capital
um Das Capital isn't um uh is not a
Manifesto he doesn't Manifesto called
The Communist Manifesto but capital is
called capital A critique of political
economy so what what he does in
capitalists he's critiquing the
classical political economists JS mail
Adam Smith Ricardo and whatnot and I
know this is pretty quite cliched for
many people and clearly that's not what
happens in the 20th century but Marx
wasn't a programmatic thinker he has
some some some parts where he says you
may need to do this this or this or he
talks about you know Civil War in France
the military Theory and whatnot but the
stuff that you see in the Soviet Union
or with the Khmer Rouge
is as connected to what Marx is talking
about as say Nazi Germany is with Edmund
buck that's my that's my view you know
it's like saying how could you be a
conservative because of look look where
it ends up when you believe in flag
family uh tradition yeah and tradition
and you know patriotism is very muscular
robustness look where it ends up look
there's been many decent people who
believe in all those things who never
ended up in that place so I I tried to
have a bit more of a nuanced View and
then in terms of where it sort of
succeeded you know look at Singapore Lee
kuang Yoo would have identified as
Democratic Socialist look he's very you
know he's very controversial figure but
Singapore and the state had a very
distinct role in its development really
from the 1950s all the way through to
today today is one of the wealthiest
countries in the world has no natural
resources
um basically people thought uh it
wouldn't last 10 minutes once the
British left I think in the early 1970s
they built an incredibly complex
sophisticated High productivity economy
how do they do that Central planning
um they promoted people on the basis of
competence and talent and they didn't
allow uh you know free market to run
Riot and so much as
um
I'm an unplanned economy there was a you
know let the uh the Invisible Hand do
its thing they didn't do that they had a
significant amount of planning and they
wanted that planning to create wealth
which would
um would lead to more prosperous country
and it worked now I'm not saying
Singapore is a socialist Paradise but on
things like for instance land actually
how land policy Works in Singapore it's
effectively a socialist policy so you
know I I think it's hard to say well
where has it worked we've got very clear
identifiable examples of socialist
policy working very well to finish it's
interesting if you compare someone like
Singapore to Venezuela Singapore has oil
none of that happens right yeah you do
not let Lee Kuan Yew and a bunch of
really intelligent competent remarkable
young men run a country if they have a
shed load of hydrocarbons because we
have many examples where people try to
do that and they mostly got murdered
um Singapore's Advantage was it had no
natural resources and it was in the same
neighborhood as Vietnam and China so the
US was actually quite happy to sort of
say well look let them do their thing
um so it's a bit more complicated that
and I I don't want to be a I hope I
never and sort of seen as an apologist
but
um I I do think there are really
important lessons to learn from
um a whole range of societies and I
think I think there are positive lessons
to learn from you know quote unquote
conservative societies I think it's
about what works
foreign